I was going everybody this is Matt we're
gonna continue on this 3d playground
video so where we left off last time let
me just bring up fork here I think we
got a block showing all right so let's
take a look and I did tagged this old
release as vid for so if anybody's
watching the previous video they can
find that source code by looking for
that tag we're gonna go ahead and go on
to video 5 this is up on github and I
might rename this to just 3d playground
and I'll tag what video it's for so
that's I think that's how I'm gonna
handle in the future I think it makes
sense okay so let's just go ahead and
hit play where we left off from last
video
see what we get it looks like we got our
window popping up and what got looks to
be a rectangle
it looks like the window resizing
doesn't really resize the viewport you
can see so normally what you do is when
you change your window size you have
this viewport you have the viewport
change to the entire screen area I
haven't set up that callback is why it
doesn't do that so it just takes the
original size and sticks with that so
we'll do that this episode will set up
some of these callbacks and we'll go
ahead and we'll get the camera and
moving around kind of like a set of
player eyes and the first person type of
view so we've got most of the camera
stuff here we're basically doing
everything in a main ok so let's just
dive into it here to get this looking
like 3d space right now we're in 2d
space we have to complete this camera
and shader stuff and that's mainly what
we're gonna do today
let's walk through it here so we enter
our main we set up a camera camera we're
not actually using yet set up our mouse
input setup keyboard input from the last
video we set all these up but they were
just like crap because we weren't
actually using them at all yet cut the
window initializing make it current
context is she bad so we can do our
opengl stuff
and we assign the shader to these files
and we load up our square and then we
all we did was really render our square
there is the reshape window handler I
got a mouse movement function this is a
first-person type of setup right here if
you were doing not first-person where
you just wanted to this X pause and Y
pause to be the position on the screen
it would you would basically assign
those directly to the X pause and Y
pause so you could do like in for
example you could have a boolean that
says if I don't know maybe it was call
the first person so if it's for first
and it would report all of this and then
you could have an else else if not
first-person and otherwise you would
report as so so we just need these this
is really no calculation to do it's just
directly the position of the screen just
doing running auto formatting there
which takes me to the bottom of the file
so there's no full first-person boolean
obviously but we could make one we could
say boolean first person equals we'll
say true but that's something we could
toggle in our game logic if we wanted to
so maybe you go into your inventory and
you want to just detect the location of
the mouse rather than process as first
person controls or something like that
that's that's kind of a standard case
I'm going to name this G first person G
is for global I'm yeah I'm doing this is
global just for now since they're not
abstracted out into classes well I tend
to get sidetracked a lot when I'm
programming I just see things I want to
work on or fix and I do it so I'm gonna
have to do some careful editing to
actually make this make sense for you
guys and it takes a lot of time for me
to do that so I would appreciate any any
feedback I can get from you guys it does
help a lot it helps keep me on track if
I'm doing something catastrophic will be
wrong
or if I'm doing something that's great
then I would also like to know cuz I
might not do it again if I don't notice
I'm doing something that works if nobody
says anything you know the viewport
should be updating which should change
this but it doesn't seem to be doing
that and I think the reason why is so we
have a reshaped window Handler is it
actually being called ever so let's do a
see out here it would be keeping that
big white square in the center if it was
so let's just take a look here no see I
resize the window it did not call the
function it would have it would have
done the see out if it was so it's not
being called and the reason why is we
haven't told GL FW which is our window
handler to to call it the way we do that
is let's see after we initialize geo
left of you we basically need to set it
up let's make some functions that set up
these handlers because they're not set
off the mouse when it the functions are
here but nothing is actually saying to
use them so we'll do a void setup
reshape window handler so on Visual
Studio you can press alt enter on and
these undefined functions and click the
little define thing and it looks like it
takes us further down in our our main
this window within a window thing is a
visual studio thing so let's go down
here to where it was or created it we
basically want to call GL fw set frame
buffer size callback so when the screen
size changes the frame buffer size needs
to update along with it and here it
needs to know about our window and our
it needs our reshape callback
so this reshape callback is what is
called every time there is a change to
the window as you can see it wants a
window and a Seabee
so it has this defined it's their own
type but basically it's a function that
needs to take a GL FW window and an int
for width and then for height so what we
can do is we can do extern see boyd
reshape callback gfw window so these are
that this is the signature it needs I'll
just call it window and we'll have a
width and a height and we don't really
need to forward declare this I don't
believe so we'll just put it right above
this and this that's what this set up
reshape window handler is going to point
to so now when this changes it's gonna
pass to this reshape callback the window
the width and height then we can do with
those whatever we want and what we're
going to do is we're gonna call our
actual reshape Handler that we
programmed and we're gonna pass it in
the window the width and the height and
I know it's a it's a weird triple
function type deal but it's the way you
have it have to do it in this case so
you have one that you call anytime you
want to change what the handlers usually
this is a one-time thing unless you're
changing controls or something but we'll
see that later and as you can see
updates the width and height as
requested and changes the viewport which
is what ends up changing the render
space do you need to call this set up
reshape handler if will do that well
basically anywhere before the main loop
but after GL if W is initialized so I
think we could do it now our window
probably needs to be initialized to and
probably the current context and GLAAD
needs to be set up probably as well so
we should be able to do it after this so
we'll just call that it'll set it up
before we get into our main loop and
that should take care of it let's hit
play and see if the window handling is
improved so there's how started no one
will resize it
our window resizes as you can see it is
calling this reshaped window handler a
bunch of times like it's every little
tic of movement I believe okay so it
seems fine here it seems fine it seems
fine and yeah now things are resizing as
expected so if you make a game or
something will change the window you can
have the report update so that doesn't
squish all weird and stuff if your
window is exactly square then this
square will be square and that's just
because of how we have it's set up with
the shader it's a very standard
orthographic projection right now let's
go ahead and get the 3d space going
that'll start making things a little
more interesting because we will start
to be able to move about our scene we
are actually not using these shaders yet
we're using the default shader and the
default shader for OpenGL just I think
it just renders everything white
so we point to this shader and the
shader doesn't throw back an error so we
know it compiles because if we look at
these files we just see that throws an
error if they have they don't compile so
this is a compile incorrectly but we
have to actually use it so the way we do
that is we would do a shader program
which is that G shader and we compile
and we just say use because it's already
all set up so we can just use it and
that will switch to these shaders before
the render and we also want to update
them because we hit play now who knows
what's gonna happen okay it's a build
error
I says G shader is not identified that's
because we're in this GL pixel loader
thing and it doesn't know about it so we
can say hey it's an extern shader called
G shader let's look at our main again
here just taking a peek at that it is a
pointer so we're gonna make sure we get
that on there and now it will know about
it but of course we do have to include
share dot H object that is somewhere
else
externally and
there's no errors it does find it and
there we go it looks like it it compiles
fine now however there's nothing on the
screen and that's because we haven't
pushed updates to the shader as required
we've already loaded up our square we
did handle that and that pushes
everything up to a vertex array called
the cube vieo
but before we render it if we don't do
this G shader that uses just rendering
to the default shader and that's why it
just works but if we are it needs more
information because this is doing some
calculations with a model of view and
projection and we haven't set any of
those so they're probably all null or
zero and that's why we're just getting a
black screen now it is getting this in
position because it's locations zero and
that's basically the location in the
vertex buffer array so if we look at
this there is a VB oh there's only one
of them and it's position zero so and
we've enabled position zero and what
that is is this here so we do have this
coming in but we don't have these coming
in and so the outputs are not working as
intended so we need to update model view
and projection and that's where the
camera comes in well the model is going
to be the size your model but the view
and projection are going to be basically
the player perspective so let's go ahead
and do that so the model is pretty easy
we're not going to change it or do
anything too special with it so all I'm
going to do here is in this render code
is I'm gonna do G shade dot set Matt for
the reasons to map for is because this
is a map for so we want to update Matt
for and it's by the name of the model
it's an exact string match basically we
want to tell it what to set it to we're
gonna set it to an identity matrix which
will keep it the same size that will be
fine
GLM matt for and i believe we just put a
1 there that is an identity identity
matrix so that just kind of pull
from that Jilin library now we need to
do need to make sure we have GLM up here
because it is customary to include
everything your file uses even if it's
being pulled in from something else we
also need to update the view and
projection so we would do something like
this set Matt for and the view but what
is this view matrix so we have to get
that and let's see we also need to
update the projection the projection is
something you will actually don't need
to update all the time I'll talk a
little more about this in a second but
the way I'm doing it here is I mean
it'll work but it's not comfortable and
the reason it's not not optimal it's
because this is happening every single
loop so it hits this render function
surrender function draws and it does
this every time well once this model is
set to an identity matrix
unless it's changing we don't need to
actually do it again because what's the
point it's hard it's already an identity
matrix so basically this is like set set
it to an identity or matrix again every
loop but it's already one so it's just a
waste of processing power to do it if it
doesn't need to do it now if you are
stretching or rotating or something yeah
you're gonna need to change this but
we'll address that and maybe a later
tutorial so the point I'm getting to
here is would probably actually want to
do this I mean I'll copy this code we
want to do this before our main loop
since it's a one-time thing right now
and just paste it here so we're gonna
say use the shader and set that model
matrix on that shader and it's not gonna
do it over and over since we're doing it
before the while loop so we'll have to
delete this one here this projection is
also really only set once and it will be
set again if we resize the window or if
we change our render distance or if we
change field of view this doesn't need
to be changed all the time if you move
around and stuff we don't need up
the projection is just when the screen
changes in some other way basically so
this we're gonna end up just doing as a
one-time thing as well but we don't know
what it is yet that's why put question
marks there so it'll give me a little
red arrow space where it is and I'll
show you how to get this projection in a
second in this view yeah we're gonna
need to update it you don't necessarily
need a update every frame but you need
to update it every frame where you move
around because it's a new view but if
you're in the exact same spatial this
certainly need to we're gonna make this
a little easier because we're not we're
not gonna be tracking movement by like
like sometimes people will have a
character move this frame or something
and if it's true then they update the
view and if it's not then they don't
worry about it I'm gonna kind of skip
over that because I'm simplifying it and
we're just going to set it every frame
because we'll likely be moving most
frames anyway ok the projection this all
comes from the camera and I started to
set up the camera in last tutorial but
now we're actually going to use it so we
want to have a starting position and the
front up and right these haven't been
set yet so we have the yaw pitch field
of view render distance and far render
distance we've got a constant world up
really we can use in our calculations
and it looks like I've defined all of
these functions right in the header so
that when I include them in the main
it'll build them so when we instantiate
the camera class we need a starting
position so that's gonna fill out this
position we're gonna need a looking
direction which is gonna be our Y all a
pitch which is how far up or down we're
looking and a field of view and this
update camera vectors is a function that
sets the front up and right based on
these position gone pitch so they're
basically some vectors at point from
your character so here's where some
other functions are built into this
camera and now this camera class Y I
have tweaked it some and maybe this is
an old version on my tweaking I'm not
sure but it originated from learn OpenGL
just for a full
clarity so if you want to get this
original file and see some other
explanations of it you can look at the
camera on learn OpenGL comm and there's
some similar explanations and maybe
worse or better view I don't know it
just depends on the person I'm gonna
kind of walk through how to update the
shader with this class of course there
are other ways of doing this this is
just how I have a set up and this is a
way that works to update our view matrix
we're going to be calling this function
and it looks like it already
sets the view so we've already set up a
camera and we've set up the look
direction to 270 and what else we got
and the pitch and yaw over there so
we've got a camera we just haven't
actually used it and it looks like we're
going to need to update it if we want to
do it here we're going to need to make
that X turn so X turn camera G camera
and that's just to use the one from the
main that we instantiate it so what
we'll do it is down here we'll say G
camera update view matrix and it wants
to know which shader and we have access
to that shader to so we can just pass it
now it's kind of weird to call global
and then pass it another global I'm
gonna be honest here but it gets the job
done in this case I'll leave it to other
people to figure out how to refactor and
your shader of course it needs to be
named view otherwise this won't work so
if we look at this set map for function
this handles all the OpenGL calls from
that shader library or include that we
have up here so we're going to shade it
us upp so when you call us at matte for
and once a name and a matte for and then
it calls well first it calls get uniform
location saves it to the ID so it needs
this name to get the uniform location
and then takes a uniform location and
passes it that map for so this is
actually two calls one call to get the
ID based on the name
and then another one to update that ID
to the matrix so if you want to save
yourself some calls you could like keep
track of all elisa ids so you don't have
to retrieve them every time and we want
to do the same thing for the update
projection matrix as you can see this
projection matrix sets it to a
perspective so if you don't want it
perspective there's a different thing to
do and this is using the GL and
perspective to get a projection matrix
and I have another function here for get
projection matrix this just returns it
and that's where if you want to do it on
your own we're basically going to do
very similar thing before except you're
we're gonna use the camera G camera
update projection matrix and this once
that shader
to know which one to update and it's
basically you're gonna take this camera
and push the projection matrix to the
shader and we don't need all this
you just need that's it camera already
has its data so it's fine so that'll
handle this model and this projection
but we need to do the view every frame
and let's see did we have that setup
looks like we do update view so this
should actually now work well notice
that we can't move around yet so I don't
set up the keyboard and mouse stuff like
they should now give us a perspective
view this is gonna look weird because
it's basically just a box might not even
work let's see what are we missing fell
we're just doing some have some syntax
errors it looks like think we just need
to include the camera which will be like
so so the same folder I think that's
what's going on here
yeah okay and so now we've got a full
read screen that seems a little weird
but the reason is the reason it's not
white is because we're using a different
shader so somewhere in this fragment
shader we have set the fragments tool to
red and I think yeah we do that right
here so this shaders real hacky
I wouldn't necessarily go off this too
directly or rather than calculating all
the light so I'm going to
later I just said it to this reddish hue
and that's what we're seeing so that is
actually part of the square and we're
just probably really close to it or
maybe even inside if it's hard to tell
but it's set to this color so that seems
to be working properly and now what we
can do is we can add in movement so we
can move about our world and we'll see
some more views as a square and it'll
make a lot more sense and now another
thing we want to do in our main is begin
to process these events we pull
so we basically if we're going to move
around on a first person what we want to
do is make a function that handles that
so this G FLW pull events tells G OFW to
take a look at where the mouse is what's
being clicked with buttons are being
pressed all of that is what this does
but to actually use them in your code
you got to do a little bit more work
because while this says okay GLW look at
what's going on it's up to the developer
to make these callback functions when
these events happen and it's very
similar to the way we did the the
reshape so this mouse one I'm gonna move
to its own little spot I'm just clean up
this code a little bit make it a little
more readable keep the mouse stuff
together because these reshapes kind of
all go together the way they call each
other that way when you're scrolling
through a giant file more than 100 lines
you can actually tell what's going on so
we have mouse functions and there's no
actual set up Mouse handler yeah so
that's why this mouse isn't being used
we're gonna need this some waiting for
the key press looks like we got all
these in here I think I copied this in
yeah I've got like every button ready to
go on this key press function I just
haven't actually called it yet so I've
got a key press it might be more
accurate to call this button press
because it's not just keys it also
processes the mouse buttons so its
keyboard and mouse buttons so maybe this
would be better named button press so
basically warrant I set up a sdw the
standard first person controls and we're
gonna set up a mouse movement for first
person that way we can
about so let's go ahead and do a void
setup Mouse Handler there's there's
multiple ways of doing this I was just
reviewing some things so you can call
these setup handlers to switch between
different things so for the Mouse
handler we're gonna have one that's
first person and we have one that's
standard just as this mouse movement
kind of specified but we can have I
think we've already kind of abstracted
that by having this first person boolean
because that just changes the way that
this mouse movement reports either for
first person to know first person so I
think we're actually okay there and
basically we just need to in a very
similar similar way as we did this
window JFW set cursor position callback
and this one also of course takes the
window in this gif LW
also once a function which is this mouse
handle so this function here is the one
that needs the signature to match this
these actually need to be doubles on the
to match the signature so this signature
actually wants doubles so now this
function it calls is this mouse movement
one but obviously it takes these doubles
and their floats so we're gonna go ahead
and translate them to floats before
passing to the function otherwise we're
gonna get some warnings and of course we
could do this with all doubles but
there's no need and I think it
interferes a little with some other
calculations potentially so we're just
gonna stick with floats cuz OpenGL likes
floats and they're half the size of a
double so that's nice
so now once we set up this mouse handler
it will run this function anytime we
move the mouse and as you can see it
basically just changes the X&Y offset of
this mouse input and then it's up to us
to move the camera based on this offset
it looks like we have our mouse
sensitivity in here so these are these
or things that could be abstracted out
into a class if you've got a class for
this so let's go ahead and get these
moving our camera it looks like we're
gonna do that during each update
basically now that we're gonna be
calling these functions automatically
just based on the callbacks we need to
actually process the information so we
pull the events at the end of a frame
but I think we want to process them at
the beginning of next frame or you can
process them at the end it will
essentially feel the same I believe but
you can play around with that and decide
what is best for you so let's make a
function here we kind of need to do a
combination of things here call it cam
movement so in this we're gonna need to
do a combination of things that includes
keeping track of where the camera is
keep track of where the mouse is
keep track of which buttons have been
pressed and that sort of thing we need
to call we need to get a button update
by calling this button press every time
so in our main here after we pull events
we want to process button press so we
need to run that maybe would be better
to call it process and this just takes
what geo f/w is reporting and puts it
into our structure process button press
and our structure is of course this
keyboard mouse input structure so it's
just gonna update all these boolean x'
every loop and we take those bullying's
from that keyboard mouse input struct
and we're gonna handle that in our cam
movement we're gonna have some statics
in here just because we haven't
abstracted out I want to fly speed I
think I'm just gonna set everything
constant yeah we'll do a current fly
speed and we'll just give it 30 that's
pretty fast maybe we'll lower it down so
we don't zoom around maybe some like 15
so we want some noclip flying so in
winning every time I call this cam
movement which is gonna be every loop
this file is getting a little bit long
at this point but basically we'll call
it say at the beginning of every loop
cam moving it so it'll take whatever
keys and stuffs going on and move the
cam accordingly before doing all the new
rendering so that's kind of the point of
that there
okay so we got a current fly speed of 15
we let's see if we want to move smoothly
we need to be processing Delta time
that's something we're not doing but
it's very easy to add in we can sort of
emulate Delta time in a way by saying
FPS will assume 60 frames per second so
this would be somewhat the velocity if
you're in your net 60 frames no this is
just a hack to skip over the Delta time
but the Delta time if you're running at
exactly 60 frames per second it's gonna
be approximately this number so I
wouldn't recommend doing this to be
perfectly honest I would recommend
actually calculating the Delta time but
I'm just doing this to save time and I
will cover Delta time in the next video
and we'll make it not so hacky and we're
gonna times this by the current fly
speed and what this allows us to do is
adjust the fly speed so if at some point
we determine okay we're going way too
slow we can add in a little function
that changes this way meet with the
mouse wheel or something and that way we
can still be calculating based on Delta
time but update the PI speed this
program will run as fast as your
computer will run it so things will be
different on every computer unless you
do something like a velocity calculation
and that this just makes it seem like a
60 frames per second no matter what so
even if you're running at 200 it will be
calculating what this Delta time still
and yeah well that's that's a bigger
topic
I'll get it more into that later so we
want to process the WASD movement here
and we're gonna add a few functions here
let's see are we're gonna hold a
direction placement and this is going to
be the new direction that we're moving
that's different from last frame so
since its static it only sets to this
zero once and it's going to be updated
every frame and where we don't call this
keys when we call it we're calling a g
keyboard input it's a pointer so this is
just different from the
other code I was working with from
something else you basically need to
reference that structure and see if the
boolean is true or not and if it is then
we update all this stuff guess we also
want our movement front and to get that
we need to call from our camera we
basically need to know where the front
of the camera is and this is just a
little unit vector that points forward
or the way we're currently looking so
the camera holds that in the front and
that's that's what we do we want to get
that right to begin with so these
statics while they stay in the function
every time they only get initialized
once so this equals is only happening
the very first time and then beyond that
we have to control them manually so
that's just the way the statics work and
all these a viewport should actually be
this G camera stuff because that's how
we're doing it in ours so if we press W
we go the direction placement is plus
equals move front times the velocity so
we're moving forward this if you press s
you're moving backwards there's a minus
on the move front press a you're moving
to the left so we take the right vector
and we go negative that direction we're
going and pressing D we're going right
so we're plus in the right direction
so this is basically handles that Wasden
movement with our current setup we could
also do some things to go up and down
and that would look something like this
you get all these updated to match our
code every time this cam movement is
call it's going to process us so if you
want to go up you have to just plus
press spacebar if you're holding shift
and pressing spacebar it's going to move
you down so this just gives you a way to
go up and down by space go up shift
space to go down so you can change that
of course how you want but that's just a
example there and then last thing we
want to do is we actually want to change
our position
his camera so we look at her camera
functions we should see one in here
called increased position so this
increased position is the one we're
looking at we want to do this at the
very end we'll call from our G camera
this increased position function and the
amount is our direction placement which
is all been calculated so every frame
we're gonna move and then we want to
just reset a few things before the next
loop that way we don't get odd things
happening one of those things is this
direction placement we're gonna set it
back to zero another way we could do
this that might be a little cleaner is
we could do it at the top of this every
time but I'm doing it at the end are you
set for next loop and our move front
let's see here you know this here we're
gonna update that as well and we're
basically gonna say okay it's the new
position of the camera so it'll be
basically be this again so that just
updates them at the very end
yes very much we could we could put
these right here like so that way
updates every frame just as well so it's
kind of a matter of how you want to your
code there's no reason to set it twice
on the first run so yeah these statics
only happen the first time but if we put
it below like this this will happen
every time so that'll update those
before the next run essentially the same
as doing it at the end so I'm just gonna
do it that way in our case so we should
be able to at least see that so okay
we'll run our file I'm gonna press s to
back up very good and press W to go
forward now if I press a I go left
do go right you can see the perspective
kicking in for this cube now and we
should be able to resize our window in
any way continue our movements now you
can see our mouse
do anything yeah and that's because we
haven't set it up but Waze is working
space goes up yep ship space goes down
okay
so the last thing we need to do is we
need to set up our mouse movement and
what we're gonna look at for that let's
go back up to the top here we've got
this mouse input and the only thing this
mouse input really is is X or Y offset
and that is updated every frame already
by this handler so anytime we move our
mouse around on the screen it is
updating but we need to actually do
something with it and we can do that
right in this cam movement we might as
well of course this could be done in a
separate function okay so mouse movement
should shift the it should move the
pitch in yaw so we haven't increased yo
increase pitch we can use those to move
our our camera around and since we
already know the offsets all we need to
do is pass these the offsets and the
rest is handled so the yaw is you know
left to right it's been kind of
indefinitely how you want but looking up
and down this is locked to 89 degrees so
you you can look almost straight down
almost straight up but only one degree
off so that that way it doesn't get all
weird and you can flip upside down and
stuff and let's see where do we want to
do that so we move the placement of the
camera already at the end of our button
press but we also want to move our mouse
and I guess this would be an okay place
to do it well you basically just take
our our G camera and we'll say increase
pitch and yaw I think yeah I have a
function that just calls both of these
and then updates the camera vectors so
we'll do that and that of course is
going to be from the GE mouse anklet so
we need to look at these variables to
decide how much G mouse input X offset
GE Mouse and play autocorrect is not
helping on this one y offset and that's
just what it once here once they offset
the pitch offset and it'll take those
and call these two functions
and then update the camera vectors so
now we should be able to just based on
adding this at the end of our cam
movement change our front vector and
that's fine because it's going to get
updated before processing the next keys
now it might be the case that this is
better somewhere else like before we'll
see let's just see how it works
sometimes you have to really think about
the order things are being processed so
we've got our window let's back up a
little if we move our mouse nothing
really happens you know we have to
question why and the reason might be
well first let's see if we even built no
they built okay we're calling cab little
bit so this should work but are we
calling the setup mouse hold on I think
we're not actually processing the mouse
yet like we built the functions here
right mouse setup Mouse handle ear house
movement but we didn't actually call it
we do set up the reshape here but we
also need to set up the mouse Handler
that way glf W actually updates that
struct so that's why it wasn't working
it's like there's a build error now 7l
scalars not to find this giant function
of keys is really taking up a lot of
space and minimizing here instead of
Mouse handler okay so we just need to
here so it knows that exists just a
little for declaration there so there we
go that should reduce that complaint and
there we go let's back up now we can
move with our mouse and sort of get
first-person but as you can see the
mouse is a go off screen it kind of
stops I don't know like you couldn't
actually play a game like this right
because the mouse is all weird but in
other ways I can move around I can move
my mouse to look around if you're using
this first-person control you have to
disable the mouse and that's a gfw thing
that basically hides the mouse and
leaves it locked on the screen if your
first person you want to do that so
I'll just make a functionary yes G first
person so first person is set to true
gia left of you set input mode on the
window so passing our window and you
tailed the cursor and then we want to
tell it how the cursor should be and
this is cursor disabled so if it's first
person we're gonna disable the cursor
and what disabling cursor does is a kind
of as I explained it doesn't actually
make the cursor not work as you would
think the word to save what kind of
means you know it actually just hides it
and lock locks it on the screen so
that's a gfw thing I know a terrible
name since it doesn't fit what it does
but GL fw that's what they call it so
you just kind of used to it so now if we
move around the cursor is now locked to
the screen so we can just keep keep
scrolling so I've lost the cube there is
so this is ideal for a first person set
up having that disabled and it looks
like I'm moving slightly oh I know okay
this is interesting so there's something
else one more mistake I made
so my hands are off the keyboard Mouse
hands off keyboard mouse is still moving
so now you'll notice you can't get your
mouse to close the window so you might
want to set the key to quit or you just
press alt f4 okay so the reason for this
of it keeping its movement is we don't
reset the X offset and wife's offset
they're staying the same so even after
we process this movement and increase
the on pitch the X offset and y offset
are not actually changed until we move
the mouse again so what we want to do
here is after we process them and say
okay we've process that movement we want
to set these to zero because the
movements done so that that was an
oddity of it continuing its movement so
now when we launch this if we get a
successful build here we should see that
now when we stop moving it stops moving
okay well I feel like we have gone over
a lot I hope this helps you guys get
your
stuff set in 3d mode and some some basic
movement going on in your program I will
upload this code with its new commits
tagged as video 5 and on link below
happy coding everybody happy new year
don't give up have any questions ask
them below peace out guys love you all
take care